πολλά πράγματα που μπορούν να αλλάξουν και τόσα πο λλ πράγματα τα οποία μεταβλητές τις
οποίες εμμπορείς νανα προβλέψεις ή να πεις που θεωρώ ότι θα ήταν τουλάχιστον επιπόλεον ή
να μην που κάμοιαν άλλη ηλέξη να πω ότι τώρα έχουν με στον νούμο τς
προετρικές πραγματι κά τεν υπαρχετς ράρα είναι γίνε καμιά σιζής όπως υπόθηκε έαι γράφτηκει αν
ότι κάποιοι σε έχουν ως το σεσυαγωγικά το άλογο τους για να τρέξουν στις προεδρικςουκάμία
σοβαρ περίπτωση νή καμια έτισι να πω σοβαρί συζήτηση ευκι γίνε τις πράμα θέλω απω
ότι τις βολευτικές θαύρουνε εξέρουμενι δεν πουν να γίνει εναι ξέρουμε ντα πολιτικό ενώ θερα
πο άλλαγίες τα βεδομένα ρα θεωρώ ότι τώρα κανένας σοβαρος άνθρωπος τησοβαρόν κόμμα έχειμε στο
νούν του τις προετρικές όταν αύριο με τούτα ούλα που βλέπουμε πε τους ούλλες τις
αλλαγές που βλέπουμε εναι ξέρει πουν να στεκρίι το κόμμανο του εγίνεση από τε προτάσι
για βουλευτκς ταξεαβολευτικέαντιλαβώνες ότι πάταημον πολιτικόπιμενου νατομο πάντα μουμσταινά ναι σίγουρατμε στις σκέψεις και με
στις τυ ζήτήσεις οι βουλευτικής θα θα το κρύψω αλλά ότιπάντα πρωτίμουν την τοπήκινα αυτογήκησηχάρις
και μου πάραπάνω το πι αυτό ικηη κι τπρηστιμή πο ανάλαβα τητο οπικίν αυτόοιδιήκηση τουράχιστον
είπα ότι τον καιρό που θαμε δήμαρχος θα πάνα πω ότο κόσμο πουμε εψήφησε ξέρεις
πιο χρόνια και να πάω βουλευτής θέλα απου ότι έννες τωστόν ότι έθηκον ν το
πράγμα και δρο να ψηφήσητης που κόμα που πολλά ακόμματα άρα γιαμένα τώρα καιο που
προέχει κι ημόνι ου ενια είαι ίνα τεποίοσο κεθυνία μο δήμαρχος και ι σ έξι
νεσε ένα χρόνο μετά π κλέίει για να απά από το κόσμου εξετεψηπίσς με γλα
σαςμ να πάω βουλευτής εναι και τ ρ και ήταν η πιο δυσκολή περίόδος που
αντιμετώπηση ένο αντρέας βυρας στη θέση του δημάρχουλα άρναχας εντάξει τονα βάγειον του λιμανιού μαρίνας
ήταν να περίοως πολλά έτσι έντονι καικαι δυσκολής αι προκλοϊγή υπεριος αντιλαβάνεσει ότι ήταν ένα
θέμα το οποίο πυ τη μιαενα ήταν παχέρκασου